scream junkie show with how Rudnick oh
hi everybody you know there are so many
award shows for movies but there's only
one award show for the worst movies the
Razzies all the nominees for the Razzies
just dropped and we are lucky enough
today to have the father of the Razzies
John Wilson John how are you sir I'm
alright doing better than the nominees
Oh zing so John how long have the
Razzies been in existence if you're old
enough to remember when John Hinckley
shot Ronald Reagan that was the first
rezzie's oh that's my fondest childhood
memory so I see that you have a Razzie
with you tell us about this ok these are
handmade if the winner wants it which
doesn't happen terribly often I accept
this award on behalf of screen junkies
for being the worst show on the entire
Internet thank you John Wilson you're
very welcome
so John are you excited to break down
the list of nominees with us a lot of
garbage to plow through you have a lot
of garbage to plow we have an esteemed
panel to help us talk about the nominees
let's introduce them we have our good
friend of the family fellow screen
junkie Nick Mundy also from belated
media Michael barity who you may recall
did that fantastic video
what if episode 1 was good we're going
to get my version of episode 1 so here
we go with what if Michael thanks for
joining us of course
guys let's start with worst picture the
nominees this year are battleship loogie
loves in big balloon adventure that's my
boy a thousand words and Breaking Dawn
Part two battleship thoughts you guys
when you look at the box it's just like
oh it's a hand playing a game like
that's all they have and they're like
well what do people like they like
aliens and they like robots and they
like explosions and let's just put all
these things that people like in a movie
and if you do that with flavors and you
try to make a dessert you're not gonna
get a good tasting dessert how dumb do
they think the audience is but the
rocket oh they're the one with the rock
in it that you say that about every
movie well yeah cuz the rock is awesome
that's my boy Adam Sandler holy cow
that's my boy uh it didn't look as bad
as Jack and Jill axe
was worse Jack and Jill was just stupid
mm-hmm that's my boy was a fence and
people just think about him Sandler as
as sheep but like what about when he was
like our generations favorite actor oh
yeah no like Billy Madison the whole air
everything but my distinct so much
moving on Eddie Murphy's back with a
thousand words when did Eddie Murphy
turn are you talking about a Nutty
Professor I can't tell the difference
between the Klumps Nutty Professor and
Norbit I'm sorry he's all the characters
it's hilarious yeah in all the movies
you could do a supercut and turn that
[ __ ] into one movie the one with Jada
Pinkett Smith it's fantastic okay was
that Norbit no that was a Nutty
Professor he's in a fat suit
oh yeah he's in a fat suit in all of
them oh [ __ ] I just stuck up for North
goddamn the son of a gun a professor
that's gonna be on your epitaph final
film Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn Part 2
this is the best of the Twilight
franchise or one of the better Twilight
movies like saying it's the best dump
you've had well that's a special moment
okay worst actor the nominees Nicolas
Cage Eddie Murphy Robert Pattinson Tyler
Perry and Adam Sandler so let's hit
these one by one
oh and I first interject real quick yeah
I'm glad that Taylor Kitsch didn't make
this list cuz it was a rough year for
Taylor Kitsch I think we could all agree
this year was a [ __ ] for Kitsch you
guys are ignoring like the worst actor
in the world yeah but right now and it's
Tyler Perry I will meet his soul let the
gates of hell before I let him
a good person that I love me not because
he's necessarily she it's just like
Tyler Perry you're Madea you don't see
ernest doing romantic comedies with meg
Ryan yeah what'd you do I really wanted
a us went to camp he went to jail and he
got scared and that's what Ernest did
you are Ernest
also nominate Pattinson he's fine it's
fine yeah
the nominees for worst actress Katherine
Heigl Mila Jovovich
Tyler Perry in drag Kristen Stewart and
Barbra Streisand for Christmas I thought
I'd take my mom to go see the guilt trip
because I forgot to get her anything
else and she hated it and then she got
mad at me so Barbra Streisand is
definitely the worst actress for ruining
Christmas I just think that Madea is
tired at this point if I come back up
these day after you still in his bed I
won't get completely legged and get up
in there with you in spoon
congratulations you've done it we're
sick of it you cannot go on you can quit
up so we hit the big three categories
worst picture worst actor worst actress
if you want to see all of the nominees
you can go to Razzies calm before we go
I want to ask you guys what was left out
glad Atlas was a piece of garbage
amazing spider-man if you're going to
reboot a movie franchise don't simply
copy/paste plot points in the exact same
order that's just lazy and we're not
stupid one thing that I noticed was
Tarantino not being nominated for worst
Supporting Actor for Django and chained
it was just such a sore thumb that was
like a piece of [ __ ] in the ice cream
panel final thoughts I just hope that
the certain makers of these films or
actors in them will make better choices
in the future 33 years later it hasn't
happened yet guys that's our Razzies
roundup what was your worst picture
worst actor worst director etc let us
know in the comments below share this
click Subscribe all that stuff thanks
for watching I'm out run dick by bike